[Music]
on this Sunday night the head of Hockey
Canada's board steps down days after her
defiant testimony I can assure the
members of the Canadian public that
change is happening scapegoat or first
step in Real Change
activists interrupt Iran's leader on
state TV
as more families mourn their daughters
the deer debate in Quebec I don't want
to see these beautiful animals Slaughter
the problem of overpopulation and calls
for a call and a Ukrainian family's
first Thanksgiving in Canada
foreign
[Music]
assar
good evening and thank you for joining
us Hockey Canada has been under the
national microscope for months its
leadership targeted by Titans of
corporate Canada citizens parents
players even the Prime Minister now a
development the interim Sheriff the
board Andrea Skinner has resigned four
days after her defensive testimony in
front of a committee examining the
handling of sexual abuse allegations as
David Akin reports MPS and others
believe this resignation should be just
the first of many in a complete overhaul
of Hockey Canada's leadership
an investigation was ongoing on Tuesday
before a parliamentary committee Andrea
Skinner was speaking up for Hockey
Canada I can ensure this committee and I
can assure the members of the Canadian
public that change is happening she
defended the practice of using
non-disclosure agreements to deal with
allegations of sexual abuse we decided
to resolve the matter in a way that was
trauma-centered victim-centered or
complainant centered and she argued
Hockey Canada's CEO and Senior
Management should not be replaced there
is a significant risk to the
organization if all of the board resigns
and all of senior leadership is no
longer there I think that will be very
impactful in a negative way to our boys
and girls who are playing hockey will
the lights stay on on the rink I don't
know but to many Skinner's comments to
stick with management only made things
worse I hope that the understand the
message and leave before they bring it
to their ground by Saturday Skinner at
least had got the message upon
Reflections he said it is clear to me
from recent events that it no longer
makes sense for me to continue I
certainly understand why she stepped
down I think Tuesday was a disastrous
hearing for Hockey Canada but at the
same time I know that the crisis in
hockey Canada is even more acute this is
the second board chair that they have
lost in two months so Hockey Canada is
now seeking a new chair and seeking new
members for its board of directors new
leaders it says must be quote committed
to a cultural Evolution for the
organization
nomination forms are at hockeycanada.ca
the deadline to apply is October 28th
David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
another sign of the growing anger in
Iran against that country's
authoritarian regime State tv there was
hacked late Saturday by a group calling
out supreme leader Ali komeni
movie
and used bulletin was interrupted by an
anonymous like mask followed by an image
of the supreme leader with flames around
him and with a Target on his head it
also included photos of four women
killed in recent protests the
interruption lasted only a few seconds
and the camera cut back to a seemingly
shocked news anchor though some have
questioned whether this was an inside
job there had been Mass protests in
cities across Iran and around the world
this weekend including here in Canada
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
passionate protesters gathered again in
Toronto this afternoon this is the
fourth week of worldwide demonstrations
that followed the death of Masa amini in
Iranian police custody she was arrested
last month for wearing what was deemed
to be inappropriate attire and she died
three days later
now there have been many protests since
the revolution more than four decades
ago but none this long or widespread as
nigar mosh tahidi reports art music and
social media are playing a major role in
raising awareness and keeping the
movement alive
foreign
[Music]
of one of the biggest uprisings Iran has
seen in decades
the artist
spent days behind bars after his song
meaning because of in English got
hundreds of millions of retweets his
lyrics based on tweets by Iranians of
their grievances against the regime each
sentence starting with because of
[Music]
sharing song really really moved me this
is kind of actually unique you know
because what we see is a is a way of
sharing the Grievances of a large
population by using the power of
internet and the the tools that the
internet provides
an expert on Iranian pop culture and
social media says hajipur song is one of
the greatest examples on how Iranians
are using social media to mobilize their
voices and to catalog what is happening
inside their country
immediately we see this you know citizen
journalism that's happening in Iran that
is very informed by what the what the
reporters need to know
[Music]
and reports emerging of several teenage
girls dying at the hands of Iran's
Security Forces this is Serena s
malzadeh
[Music]
during happier times now allegations she
was beaten to death for protesting for
basic freedoms her story similar to that
of Nika Shah karami a teenager who
joined protests on September 20th
according to the Oslo base group Iran
human rights she was also killed the
regime vehemently denying that and
Hadith najafi 23 years old reportedly
killed shot multiple times during
protests their stories would be Untold
had it not been for the sharing of
information online you can stop them
slowly and you can suppress them
temporarily but that doesn't stop them
from continuing to share and circulate
also emerging from the tragedy art in
the form of resistance
graphic designers from around the world
drawing attention to the cause through a
form of protest art
but rokney warns that social media has a
short attention span and persistence is
key to keeping the movement alive
negarmo Shahidi Global News
to the war in Ukraine now a Russian
missile strike on the city of zapparisha
has killed at least 13 people injuring
many others including children this
comes a day after that huge explosion
damaged the Kirch bridge between Crimea
and Russia the cause of which is still
uncertain but Russian President Vladimir
Putin is blaming Ukraine for an act of
Terror and that's raising more worries
about what he'll do next Redmond Shannon
reports
traffic sneaks back for up to eight
kilometers drivers attempting to leave
Crimea on the remaining Lanes of the
Kirch Bridge the queue of cars at least
partly down to traffic limits along the
intact Lanes of the bridge trucks are
now forced to use ferries as teams
inspect the damage Saturday's explosion
destroyed one section of Road and spread
to rail cars Russia says some train
traffic has resumed but it's difficult
to verify footage released by Russian
State media while we're still waiting to
see the full impact uh you know Russia
clearly has to think twice about using
this bridge Russian President Vladimir
Putin says Ukraine is to blame for what
he calls a terror attack on the
structure it was built after Russia
annexed Crimea in 2014 that this bridge
was perhaps the Pinnacle of Russia's
symbolism for having control over Crimea
for for trying to force Ukraine under
Russian domination and that symbol has
gone up literally in Smoke Ukraine has
not claimed responsibility theories
abound that achieve may have used a
high-spec U.S missile or even a drone
boat like this one reportedly found in
Crimea last month the bridge is a key
Supply route for Russia's military
particularly as it looks to hold off
Ukrainian advances in Curson region with
Russian troops being pushed back there
are concerns about what Putin's reaction
will be he's recently made thinly veiled
threats about using nuclear weapons
but perhaps one indication was seen in
zapparija Sunday more deaths in the
Ukrainian city after a missile attack on
a civilian area the second such attack
in three days Redmond Shannon Global
News London
Canada's Federal housing agency is
sounding the alarm on affordable housing
it's warning that unless urgent
proactive measures are taken by all
levels of government we won't be able to
build enough housing to meet demand and
gaviola explains why labor shortages are
at the heart of the issue
though some of this steam has come out
of the housing market affordability will
continue to be a problem unless drastic
measures are taken quickly that's the
takeaway from a new report from Canada's
Federal housing agency problems are most
acute in Ontario that shouldn't come as
a great surprise but also in BC and to a
lesser extent in Alberta and Quebec we
don't have enough construction industry
workers to build the three and a half
million additional homes needed in the
next eight years to meaningfully improve
affordability we will have to double
more than double our maximum capacity at
the current rates in order to achieve
that
Crews have become more efficient during
the pandemic building more with less
people but the industry is stretched
it's not all doom and gloom through in
2020 and 2021 what we did find were that
essentially most sites and and in the
construction sector was making do with
fewer people and producing more units
cmhc offers Solutions including more
high density construction stepping up
Renovations and conversions of existing
buildings to create new homes increasing
Canada's already lofty immigration
targets to bring in workers with the
skills needed to build and attracting
more young people to the industry all
levels of government will need to be
involved as well as private sector
developers and it's not just about
building more units dwellings must be
suitable for people's needs a lot of
these condo units that are being built
particularly in places like Toronto or
Vancouver are small and they're not
really catering for families with
children more space so this that's going
to be a challenge labor shortages aren't
unique to construction similar issues
plague the hospitality and Healthcare
Industries economists say this will
weigh on growth it's likely costing our
economy something in the neighborhood of
more than 50 billion dollars of of
economic activity Deloitte is
forecasting a short recession by Year's
End Silver Lining companies say they are
reluctant to lay off workers even if
there is an economic downturn for fear
of not being able to hire them back when
things improve worker scarcity equals
job security and gaviola Global News
Toronto
across Canada 21 people each day are
dying due to toxic drugs and overdoses
for Years BC has been the epicenter of
that crisis now statistics show there is
a disturbing new trend overdoses from
smoked drugs are on the rise Anita
gercha explains the new challenges that
poses for Advocates who want to help
it's one of Vancouver's oldest
neighborhoods where tragically some of
the newest Innovations in BC's response
to the overdose epidemic are born you're
using an alley or they're using a back
alley drug policy advisor Karen Ward
says she sees firsthand the need for
more adaptation to the trend seen over
the last six years towards smoking
they're vaping off foil they're using
their they're vaporizing the um the
substance and inhaling the smoke and the
downtown east side is at the epicenter
of the epidemic we should be obviously
mandating on safer smoking rooms in um
in in like in public buildings while
there are multiple supervised injection
sites there's only one safe inhalation
site in this area and some like this
indigenous Outreach worker say that's
not enough I've actually seen people
smoking just outside the safe injection
sites you know trying doing their best
to be safe as possible when they're
injecting the infections will come I
think that's whether the trends started
where they started smoking the latest
figures from the BC coroner service show
smoking is the most used mode of
consumption leading to toxic drug deaths
across BC in some regions these inhaled
doses cause a vast majority of the
fatalities such as 74 percent of
Overdose deaths in the province's
northern interior last year they've been
slower to open inhalation sites because
in those cold climates they have just
the necessity to have ventilation safety
for workers is compounded by the climate
BC's minister of mental health and
addiction says they're constantly
looking for new approaches especially as
the country's first jurisdiction to
decriminalize drug use and permitting
the prescription of safe Supply this
hasn't been done before you know and and
so and so we're learning as we go
we're funding every health authority to
stand inhalation supervised consumption
sites up and honestly we just have got
our heads down every day on designing
new ways to tackle this crisis all right
love you
James Harry senior says for his people
who were disproportionately affected by
the crisis a culturally appropriate
response is critical knowing that they
got a little taste of home just a little
taste right yeah and that that goes a
long way as many of those on the front
lines continue to be relied upon to
inform the next steps in the evolving
response nitu Garcia Global News
Vancouver
coming up North Korea's neighbors
respond to its latest missile tests and
Canada's foreign affairs minister pays a
rare visit to the region
North Korea fired two more missiles into
the sea the latest in a blitz of weapons
tests in recent days hours later
Canada's foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie currently on a visit to
South Korea and Japan made a rare trip
to the demilitarized zone
from the Fortified border between the
two koreas Julie tweeted I was struck by
what it represents it separates freedom
from oppression Prosperity from hardship
in many ways it is a symbol of peace but
also of its fragility
she's the latest in a string of leaders
to visit the Zone in recent weeks
including U.S vice president Kamala
Harris this weekend's launch comes after
the U.S and South Korea wrapped up a new
round of Naval drills off the Korean
Peninsula Pyongyang says these drills
are threatening Regional security but as
Jennifer Johnson reports the U.S is not
backing down a new round of military
drills between the nuclear-powered
aircraft carrier USS Ronald Reagan and
South Korean warships has drawn sharp
criticism from North Korea's defense
Ministry calling them provocative and
threatening but the U.S is defending the
exercises we're going to make sure that
we have the capabilities in place to
defend our national security interests
if it comes to that the U.S Japan and
South Korean military drills come as
North Korea fires powerful missiles over
Japan two on Sunday and one last Tuesday
that went farther than ever before
triggering alerts warning residents to
prepare to evacuate and anger from the
U.S the United States condemns these
actions in the past two weeks North
Korea has fired multiple ballistic
missiles into the sea adding to its
record number of weapons tests this year
North Korea says it is building up its
nuclear program to respond to U.S
threats concerning military analysts
that a future nuclear attack is a real
possibility his research and development
is moving along and so it's more likely
that he has this capability I think in
the end it comes down to will he ever
use it the U.S and South Korea have
repeatedly said they have no plans to
attack the north but North Korea isn't
buying that as it embarks on a major
escalation and public show of its
potential nuclear power Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington
I had the challenging choices over too
many deer in a Quebec Park
animal rights Advocates are promising to
continue to find a Quebec municipality's
plan to Cull its deer population at a
park outside Montreal Mike Armstrong
explains
anyone considers the deer in this park
to be pests it's more of a too much of a
good thing situation but much too much
well I don't want to see these beautiful
animals slaughtered
the city of Lange's controversial
solution to its deer overpopulation
problem is an organized call the plan is
to shut the park down for a few days and
send in Hunters with crossbows they're
very cute and everything but I don't see
any choice
Michelle Park isn't big it's only about
two square kilometers large enough
according to the city for 10 to 15 Deer
the herds blown past that things started
to be a problem back in 2017 when the
population was at 20. four years later
it ballooned to 72 deer and as of this
summer it was a hundred and eight
well there's been a battle brewing for a
few years over what to do the cities
argued the cult is needed the deer are
too domesticated to be moved too
dangerous to vehicles in the area and
are eating too much vegetation if we
want to save and protect the park we
need to do this now we can't wait many
more years otherwise we're just going to
lose the park
animal rights groups took the city to
court last week asking a judge to
suspend the planned call the decision
came Monday the judge siding with the
city we're not quite ready to give up
two different groups now say they'll
appeal the Montreal SPCA and softage
animal rescue they say the judge made
mistakes in the ruling allowing an
unfair solution to a problem the city's
neglect and mismanagement caused how for
decades now they've been feeding the
deer
so as a result the the deer like all the
rest of us who are overfed don't just
become fat and happy but we make a lot
more babies now both sides say they
would like to relocate the deer the city
says too many would die if moved into
the wild while animal rights groups say
almost all of them will die otherwise
only 10 to 15 will be kept the groups
say at a minimum young healthy animals
could be moved but the clock is ticking
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
next the first of many Thanksgiving for
a newly arrived Ukrainian family
there are so many precious things to be
thankful for this Thanksgiving weekend
loved ones like your friends and family
but for one Ukrainian family who managed
to escape Russia's gruesome war on their
Homeland traveling all the way here to
Canada they're just thankful to no
longer be in danger
here when we found the apartment I was
so happy and they could sit and finally
breathe out and sleep well because I
knew that we don't have to run we're
just grateful to universe that we can be
here in safe place with such a wonderful
people around it's Canadians
when Kate shishko her mother and
daughter fled their home in Ukraine and
got to Canada they had no host family to
welcome them they were just lucky to
find a landlord who let them rent
without a job or any references Calgary
is now their home and now they're even
helping another Ukrainian family
displaced by War all this as they
prepare to celebrate their first
Thanksgiving in Canada
we wish them a very happy first
Thanksgiving in Canada and we hope
you're enjoying your Thanksgiving and
time with your family
maybe you're at a pumpkin Festival like
this one
this is in Richmond Hill and it features
everything from a costume contest to a
pumpkin patch pony rides a rock climbing
wall pumpkin bowling and even a pumpkin
Express Train ride
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us have a Happy Thanksgiving
tonight's your Canada fall color is here
at sherbet Lake Ontario Nita Garcia will
be at the anchor desk tomorrow until
next time take care of yourselves and
each other good night